I am going to first tell you something
that in my grandmother would have
elicited a 500 arm well your your your
yours and here it is are you ready okay
I have a Stage four lung cancer oh I
know poor me I don't feel that way I'm
so okay with it
and granted I have certain advantages
not everybody can take so Cavalier in
attitude I don't have young children I
have a grown daughter who's brilliant
and happy and wonderful I don't have
huge financial stress my cancer isn't
that aggressive it's kind of like the
Democratic leadership not convinced it
can win it's basically just sitting
there waiting for goldman sachs to give
it some money oh and the best thing of
all i have a major accomplishment under
my belt yes I didn't even know it until
someone tweeted me a year ago and here's
what they said you are responsible for
the pacification of the American male
not that I can take all the credit but
but what if you don't have my advantages
the only advice I can give you is to do
what I did
make friends with reality you couldn't
have a worse relationship with reality
than I did from the get-go I wasn't even
attracted to reality if they'd had
tinder when I met reality I would have
swipe left and the whole thing would
have been over and reality and I we
don't share the same values the same
goals to be honest I don't have goals
I have fantasies they're exactly like
goals but without hard work I'm not a
big fan tired work but you know reality
it's either you know push push push push
push it through its agent the executive
reigning function which I hit at one of
the yeas of dying my executive brain
function will not neither kick around
anymore
but something happened that made me
realize that reality may not be reality
so what happened was because I basically
wanted reality to leave me alone but I
wanted to be left alone in a nice house
with a wolf range and sub-zero
refrigerator private yoga lessons I
ended up with the development deal at
Disney and one day I found myself in my
new office on two dopey Drive
it's reality thought I should be proud
of and I'm staring that the present they
sent me to celebrate my arrival not the
Lalique Vaz or the grand piano I've
heard of other people getting but a
three-foot-tall stuff Mickey Mouse with
a catalog in case I wanted to order some
more stuff that didn't jive with my
aesthetic and when I looked up in the
catalogue to see how much this three
foot high Mouse cost here's how it was
described life-size and that's when I
knew reality wasn't reality reality was
an imposter
so I dived in to quantum physics and
chaos theory to try to find actual
reality and I've just finished a movie
yes finish about all that so I won't go
into it here and anyway it was until
after we shot the movie when I broke my
leg and then it didn't heal then they
had to do another surgery or later and
then that took a year two years in a
wheelchair and that's when I came into
contact with actual reality limits there
was very limits I'd spent my whole life
denying and pushing past and ignoring
were real and I had to deal with them
and they took imagination and creativity
and my entire skill set it turned out I
was great at actual reality I didn't
just come to terms with it I fell in
love and I should have known
given my equally shaky relationship with
the zeitgeist I'll just say if anyone's
in the market for a Betamax
I should have known that the moment I
fell in love with reality the rest of
the country would decide to go in the
opposite direction but I'm not here to
talk about Tron for the alt riot or
climate change deniers or even the
makers of this thing which I would have
called a box except that right here it
says this is not all box they're
gaslighting me but what I do want to
talk about is a personal challenge to
reality that I take personally and I
want to preface it by saying that I
absolutely love science I have this not
a scientist myself but an uncanny
ability to understand everything about
science except the actual science which
is math but the most outlandish concepts
make sense to me the string theory the
idea that all of reality emanates from
the vibrations of these teeny I call it
the big twang wave particle duality the
idea that one thing could manifest is
two things you know that a photon can
manifest as a wave and a particle
coincided with my deepest intuitions
that people are good and bad ideas are
right and wrong Freud was right about
penis envy and he was wrong about who
has it
thank you and then there is this even a
slight variation on that which is
reality looks like two things but it
turns out to be the interaction of those
two things like space-time mass energy
and life and death I don't understand I
simply just don't understand the mindset
of people who are out to defeat death
and overcome death how do you do that
how do you defeat death without killing
off life I it doesn't make sense to me I
also have to say I find it incredibly
ungrateful I mean you're given this
extraordinary gift life but it's as if
you would ask Santa for a rolls-royce
Silver Shadow and you've gotten a salad
spinner instead you know it's the beets
the big beef with it is that it comes
with an expiration date
death is the deal-breaker I don't get
that I don't understand it's
disrespectful it's disrespectful to
nature the idea that we're going to
dominate nature we're going to master
nature nature is too weak to understand
our intellect no I don't think so I
think if you've actually read poncy such
as I have well I read any email from
someone who'd read it but
you have to understand that we don't
live in Newton's clockwork universe
anymore we live in a banana peel
universe and we won't ever be able to
know everything or control everything or
predict everything nature's like a
self-driving car the best we can be is
like the old woman in that joke I don't
know if you've heard it a woman an old
woman is driving with her middle-aged
daughter in the passenger seat and the
mother goes right through a red light
and the daughter doesn't want to say
anything that makes it sound like you're
too old to drive so she didn't say
anything and then the mother goes
through a second red light and the
daughter is tactfully as possible says
mom are you aware that you just went
through two red lights and the mother
says Oh am i driving
[Applause]
so and now I am going to take a mellow
leap which is easy for me because I'm
the Evel Knievel of mental leaps my
license plate says cogito ergo zoom I
hope you're willing to come with me on
this but my real problem with the
mindset that is so out to defeat death
is if your anti-death which to me
translates as anti life which to me
translates as anti nature it also
translates to me as anti woman because
women have long been identified with
nature and my source on this is Hannah
Arendt the German philosopher who wrote
a book called the human condition and in
it she says that classically work is
associated with men work is what comes
out of the head it's what we invent it's
what we create it's how we leave our
mark upon the world whereas labourer is
associated with the body it's associated
with the people who perform labor or
undergo labor so to me the mindset that
denies that that denies that were in
sync with the bio rhythms the cyclical
rhythms of the universe does not create
a hospital environment the hospital
environment for women or for people
associated with labor which is to say
people that we associate as descendants
of slaves or people who perform manual
labor so here's how it looks from a
banana peel universe point of view from
my mindset which I call Emily's universe
first of all I am incredibly grateful
for life but I don't want to be immortal
I have no entry I have no interest in
having my name live on after me and in
fact I don't want it to
because it's been my observation that no
matter how nice and how brilliant or how
talented you are fifty years after you
die they turn on you
yeah and I have actual proof of that a
headline from the Los Angeles Times and
Frank not so nice after all
plus I love being in sync with the
cyclical rhythms of the universe
that's what's so extraordinary about
life it's a cycle of generation
degeneration regeneration I am just a
collection of particles that is arranged
into this pattern then will decompose
and be available all of its constituent
parts to nature to reorganize into
another pattern to me that is so
exciting and it makes me even more
grateful to be part of that process you
know I look at death now from the point
of view of a German biologist andreas
weather who looks at it as part of the
gift economy you're given this enormous
gift life you enrich it as best you can
and then you give it back and you know
Auntie Mame said life is a banquet
well I've eaten my fill I have had an
enormous appetite for life I've consumed
life but in death I'm going to be
consumed I'm going into the ground just
the way I am and there I invite every
microbe and a traitor sir and a
composter to have their I think they'll
find me delicious I do so the best thing
about my attitude I think is that it's
real it's not you can see it you can
observe it it actually happens it's not
as well maybe not my enriching the gift
I don't know about that but my life has
certainly been enriched by other people
by Ted to introduce me to a whole
network of people who have enriched my
life by including Trisha McGillis my
website designer I was working with my
wonderful daughter to take my website
and turn it into something where all I
have to do is write a blog I don't have
to use this brain function ha ha ha
and I'm so grateful to you I don't want
to say the audience because I don't
really see it as we're two separate
things
I think of it in terms of quantum
physics again and you know quantum
physicists are not exactly sure what
happens when the wave becomes a particle
there are different theories the
collapse of the wavefunction decoherent
but they're all agreed on one thing that
reality comes into being through an
interactions and every other house I've
ever had past and present thank you so
much for making my life real
[Applause]